buenas tardes la cumbre de líderes
europeos hace escasos minutos que ha
terminado aquí en bruselas en que uno de
los temas principales de la de hoy ha
sido la migración un asunto igual de
divisivo que el que se mantuvo ayer con
la situación derivada por la sentencia
del tribunal constitucional en polonia y
también el aumento de los precios de la
energía en la unión europea en todo caso
sobre la migración preocupar sobre cómo
actuar especialmente como comentabas
raúl sobre la situación en las fronteras
exteriores especialmente en los países
de lituania y polonia que son
colindantes con belarús recordemos que
este país está utilizando a migrantes
provenientes de afganistán siria e irak
los envía hasta la frontera con la unión
europea muchos mueren de frío o también
mueren de hambre en las fronteras de la
unión europea todo para presionar como
una represalia por las sanciones del
bloque que lleva manteniendo un pulso
con vela rusa desde hace casi un año
contra el régimen de alexandr lukashenko
finalmente los líderes europeos han
decidido aumentar está a presión estas
sanciones y aún así también se habla de
nuevas medidas se ha discutido la
situación de que se quiera se pueda
aplicar un muro pero esto tiene requiere
dudas morales aún así la comisión
europea se ha comprometido a estudiar
qué medidas se pueden tomar para parar
esta presión también se estudia
sancionar a aerolíneas que envían a los
migrantes las fronteras exteriores de la
unión europea en cuestiones que se deben
estudiar aun porque la situación de la
migración preocupa mucho a todos los
países europeos en cualquier caso todo
esto se ha producido en la última
reunión de angela merkel como canciller
de alemania que ha recibido una ovación
y un regalo por estos 16 años siendo la
líder que más tiempo ha estado en este
edificio al consejo europeo